hello
did you hear the news dali 2 has a
secret language if one let's tally 2
generate an image from apoplaw vs
reality it will generate birds kontara
czech nyams
generates bugs or pests
miss coffee bean are you drunk
in this video we will discuss what the
discoverers of this phenomenon have told
us on twitter and in their archive paper
about this we will see what theories the
community has come up with to explain
how dali 2 can generate sensible output
from gibberish
and we will realize that we should guard
ourselves from the incoming flood of
clickbait titles because spoilers but no
dalitu does not have an own language
language or not dalitus gibberish is an
interesting phenomenon to look at
nonetheless so let's discuss this in
this ai coffee break
but before we dive in let's thank
weights and biases for supporting us in
this video today we are discussing
dalit2 from openai that generates images
from text only that the code and weights
for this model are not released but dali
mini and ali mega are open source
projects by boris daima that replicate
open ai's efforts and the cool thing is
that boris used weights and biases
reports to track and communicate his
progress of course because weights and
biases reports are incredibly flexible
allowing to communicate your work to
colleagues managers or even just
yourself in this report boris is keeping
a training journal of how his latest
model training is going which he updates
regularly with notes about new
experiments and changes to the model's
training regime that he's trying reports
are a great tool for education and
sharing analysis for your colleagues or
the wider world
the report here is more polished than
the previous one and contains
educational graphics as well as
interactive weights and biases charts
and tables to help the reader understand
the results of his work
finally for those of us with not enough
time reports are a perfect way to create
a concise real-time and high-level
dashboard for a more focused summary of
how a project or model is doing go to
1db dot me slash ai minus coffee minus
break to explore and interact with these
reports yourself and see how reports can
help you share your work with colleagues
around the world
okay so here's the news we have this
texture image generation model dalit2
from openai it's a diffusion model that
can take in text and produce an amazing
picture if you're interested in how
text-to-image diffusion models work
check out our previous videos on this
but now here's the catch dalit ii can
not only take insensible input text and
produce its best shots at an image from
this but no it can take in gibberish and
produce output that looks really good
and even more it seems like this
gibberish does mean something for the
model because the combination of
something that produces birds with
something that produces bugs in apoplos
reality realities eating contara chat
nyams lurikatanyonuns
gives images of birds eating bugs
is this language
no it's not as the authors have quickly
realized after announcing their findings
on twitter and changed their paper title
from secret language to secret
vocabulary
language has syntax and grammar but ali
too seems rather to respond at gibberish
words
so how did the authors find and generate
such examples
it seems like the discovery happened
while the authors were playing with the
text rendering capabilities of dali 2.
the model is already known to produce
very weird results on this
so they gave the model an input where it
had to produce text like two farmers
talking about vegetables with subtitles
and found that the produced text is not
as random as one might think this word
vikutez produces dishes with vegetables
and apoplo vesraetars produces birds
so the authors concluded that the
farmers must be talking about birds
messing with their vegetables in this
thread you can see other examples too
but what we see there and in the paper
are not really many examples and it is a
bit unclear on what the success rate of
this method is
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
as highlighted in this thread where only
4 out of 10 examples generate sports
from the word tibur even though like in
the farmer's examples those two men
speak about tibor which seems to be
about sports so why does this even
happen that tali2 generates good looking
pictures from gibberish
the authors make the fuzzy claim that
the model has internally developed a
hidden language
we mean vocabulary after being trained
on image text pairs
well this is not very specific so let's
look at the theories circulating on
twitter right now because there are a
few very interesting ones the first one
i saw was by yoshabach he points out
that the text generations are quite
inconsistent
in the paper the authors prompt dali too
with two whales talking about food with
subtitles but yo shabbat points out that
the secret words one gets from this are
different every time
so your shabbat goes on saying that the
secret words are just random strings
that sometimes point to consistent
regions in the embedding space
the model projects the samples into high
dimensional space and clusters
neighboring concepts then honestly i do
not get what the rest of the explanation
wants to say maybe you know so go to the
comments and explain it if you want
so here is miss coffee beans take on
this which
might be very different from the one in
this thread sorry
the model has a limited number of
parameters and for efficiency reasons it
needs to cluster the space of words well
so concepts that are related to one
another should be close in this space
since we are working with neural
networks the text is represented as
continuous vectors but surprise text is
discrete and is composed of words that
do not have an in between as continuous
vectors do and since the model always
must produce an output whatever the
input the in between words so gibberish
will also produce an output
as it turns out this is sometimes
consistent between the string input and
rendered text in the image how seldomly
this works and how inconsistent this is
is highlighted by another twitter user
who points out that the bug producing
prompt does not produce so many bugs or
pests after all since in these daily two
generations we also have animals like
deer and goats
still along the line of the discreetness
of language are the opinions that say
that the secret language is mostly due
to tokenizer effects since apodi de and
plo seide are families of birds each
with more than 100 species apple deforms
is the biggest order of birds with 400
and more species of birds
so the model has connected the apple and
plow subwords to words somebody else
found that one can infer some of these
subwords that will work with dali too by
looking at wikipedia
where
actinopterygie and placodermi are two
families of fish and then placo actin
fig
generates fish images
you know with neural networks sometimes
it is great input in garbage out
now it's gibberish in quality images out
and everybody freaks out
it's clear that we do not yet understand
these black boxes and unless some more
rigorous interpretability goes into
these models we will continue prompting
in the dark and we will hope for the
best it's important to highlight that as
long as we are surprised by this weird
way of communication from daddy to and
similar models we are also ignorant of
some security issues adversarial attacks
with these gibberish prompts as well as
not so gibberish prompts can trigger
unwanted behavior from others
circumventing filters on the allowed
inputs it's clear that so far these
models do not behave like humans would
expect them to and malicious humans
could take advantage of this
what do you think about this would you
be interested to enroll in miss coffee
beans dali 2 language classes
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you